[Music]
in this video today we are going to
answer a question that has been plaguing
a lot of people's minds and that is if
godzilla can be called a dinosaur kaiju
or a dragon kaiju many of us know that
godzilla has features that could be
attributed to both glasses of reptiles
and yes he is mainly a reptilian kaiju
well except for the anime godzilla earth
where he has a plan based life form for
some reason many of godzilla's fans say
that he is a dinosaur kaiju because he
was designed by taking the t-rex or at
least the old t-rex model where it was
standing upright into consideration
others asked about the famous atomic
breath and that it was obviously
inspired by flame breathing dragons so
this one is a doozy anyway let's hit
this topic right away
anyway let's start with godzilla's
origins within the context of the
japanese films godzilla's exact origins
vary but it is generally depicted as an
enormous violent prehistoric sea monster
awakened and empowered by nuclear
radiation the tri-star godzilla was
actually an iguana so let's leave that
one out and also godzilla earth where it
is a plan based life form most of us
godzilla evolved before the dinosaurs
even came to be basically even before
reptiles so this makes it even hard to
classify this kaiju as a dragon or a
dino shin and singular point doesn't
even make it any easier with their
rapidly evolving forms that changes from
aquatic to terrestrial in the span of a
few days
so let's see that similarities between
godzilla and dinosaurs
originally thought of as a mythical
dinosaur-like creature with the ability
to breathe atomic energy godzilla
resembles a tyrannosaurus rex in that it
has short arms and has armoured plates
on its back that resembles large bony
maple leaves similar to those on a
stegosaurus
gaza is actually
a deformed unique species of dinosaur
called godzillasaurus according to the
1991 film godzilla vs king ghidorah and
a fun fact there is an actual dinosaur
whose fossils would die up and given the
name gojirasaurus
the godzillasaurus from the movie gives
the dino theory a credible edge and it
is canon to the kaiju this dino is
different from other theropods because
its posture is more upright and at 12
meters in height it is much larger than
any other it has a smaller head and has
a double row of teeth but most of all it
is the one that was exposed to radiation
giving rise to the big g
but this is only true for the heisei
incarnation while others from the show
era to the millennium and others did not
share the same origin story
so the question now is what
distinguishes dinosaurs from other
reptiles well reptiles such as
crocodiles and lizards have legs that
sprawl out to the side
their thigh bones are almost parallel to
the ground they walk and run
on a side to side motion dinosaurs on
the other hand stand with their legs
position directly under their bodies a
hole in the hip socket permits permits
this upright stance this posture allows
dinosaurs to run faster and with greater
endurance than other reptiles that are
the same size and that was the
definitive evolutionary design that
differentiates dinos from other reptiles
and as far as to our knowledge godzilla
also have the same characteristics
so now let's shift to the similarities
between godzillas and dragons godzilla
might be classified as a dragon but not
in the classic sense godzilla is a
wingless dragon that is solely anchored
to earth which could be referred to as a
terrestrial grounded dragon and before
we label him as a kaiju keep that in
mind the dragons can also be considered
kaiju since the word kaiju literally
means giant monster and that is a vague
term given that even ghidorah a kaiju is
also a three-headed dragon on one hand
he is a humanoid dinosaur-like dragon
that is godzilla and he breeds radiation
not five per se and he has a sci-fi
origin he has a destructive giant
reptile with a heat-based breath weapon
under a loose definition yes he is a
dragon type kaiju but his sci-fi
dinosaur origins also makes him more of
a unique paradox
an extract from the medievalist called
sarah dunn well she said that in
japanese lore the dragon deity called
ryujin is considered the god of the sea
in the region shinko an offshoot of the
japanese religion shinto there's even a
dragon palace at the bottom of the sea
further connecting japanese dragons to
the oceans that surround the island
nation though based in part of the
japanese dragons like region godzilla
takes on a new composite form as
godzilla is an entirely new form of
destruction this theory brings up valid
arguments to consider godzilla as a
dragon as he is both mysterious and
destructive
has powers and is a reptile and there
are also various other sea dragons in
global myths like the leviathan and the
magara which do not at all look like
modern depictions of dragons with wings
so with that we come to the other side
of the story the differences well we are
going to look at the dinosaur godzilla
differences as well as the dragon
godzilla differences now let's see
godzilla is way too big to be an actual
dinosaur which can be held up in a
debate
except for the heisei incarnation which
was definitively shown to be a dino
exposed to radiation and then evolve
into the big j in other versions
it's first of all way too big secondly
dinosaurs don't have energy based
breaths thirdly godzilla originated in
the modern era and maybe in the future
for other versions millions of years
later after the kt extinction event
which wiped out all dinosaurs so what
about the dragon theory gossip isn't
actually a winged dragon in the modern
sense it has no wings but there are also
lots of other sea dragons and wingless
ones too godzilla is definitely not
anything like a western or even a
chinese dragon in design and also he
doesn't have a serpentine body
like most dragons are traditionally
depicted so what is he
so what is our conclusion well godzilla
definitely has the evolutionary trait of
dinosaurs in that he is a reptile that
can stand upright due to the few sacral
bones in the pelvis region aside from
the heisei incarnation the others can
only be loosely classified as having
dinosaur-like traits other than that
godzilla as a dragon theory has a lot of
weight on it mostly because dragons are
vacant definition
and he fits the role perfectly as the
sea dragon with the men's powers that
could be considered magical in the olden
times so what is godzilla a dragon or a
dino not truly one or the other but a
mix of both that is our conclusion and
with that we come to the end of the
video do like for support subscribe and
smash that bell button for regular
updates on new master videos right here
on this channel till next one take care
fam